Oh
the word in theo genic means god
facilitating and it's this idea that
tools and techniques and ecstasy can act
as conduits as mediation catalysts for
encounters with the numinous they are
essentially God hats okay it's this
notion that we are able to treat our
subjective experience to catalyze a
shift in consciousness that leads us to
a kind of God in a sense
give into the astonished realization
that reality is but a matrix of
perception that we can pierce that veil
that we can raise the stage is
astonishing it means we are
ontologically engineers we are the music
makers and we are the dreamers of dreams
indeed we tumble down that rabbit only
rien scribe we define re-edit the nature
of that rabbit so the Wonderland because
our Wonderland this hero's journey
becomes the map for our own ecstatic
illumination of this notion you know
Murcia and the idea the Philosopher's
talked about techniques of ecstasy he
described shamans as literally ecstatic
technicians of the sacred this is my
dream right this notion that we actually
are able to look up to create conditions
to create spaces for all of us to become
ecstatic technicians of the sacred that
the passports of the numinous lies
within
we can hack it that there is a God huge
etic revolution boundaries are being
dissolved we are being born it is our
birthright
it is our birthplace we are asking God's
might as well get good at cognitive
experts
metacognitive ecstasy is within